tina und daniel
ein neubeginn
[Musik]
jetzt bin ich in der schweiz angekommen
ich freue mich auf meine neue stelle
ich glaube dass zürich sehr klein ist
taxi taxi wohin darf ich sie fahren zu
meiner neuen wohnung an der hohlstrasse
sind sie neu in der schweiz willkommen
in zürich
ja ich bin soeben gelandet mein flug war
schneller als ich gedacht habe
woher kommen sie denn haben sie ein
meeting in zürich
[Musik]
nein ich arbeite hier nächste woche
beginne ich bei der bank in westick com
[Musik]
ich komme aus new york da habe ich
bereits bei investec com gearbeitet
jetzt darf ich in zürich arbeiten wo das
ist interessant ich wollte schon immer
mal nach new york
und wieso sprechen sie so gut deutsch wo
haben sie das gelernt ich habe in new
york einen deutschkurs besucht
[Musik]
und ich habe viele videos der halo
deutsch schule gesehen
diese helfen mir beim deutsch lernen
[Musik]
eine katze ist auf der straße zum glück
ist der katze nichts passiert
vielen dank für die fahrt wie viel
kostet das vom flughafen in die stadt
das macht 27 franken 30
hier sind 30 franken
der rest ist für sie
hier ist also meine neue wohnung die mir
die bank vermittelt hat
[Musik]
ich hätte gern einen cheeseburger eine
portion pommes frites und eine cola mit
viel eis
gerne
möchten sie das essen mitnehmen oder
hier essen ich esse gern hier
das macht 12 franken 20
ich bezahle mit karte
guten appetit
mein job ist ja sooo langweilig china
nicht schlafen
entschuldigung
hier wird gearbeitet und nicht
geschlafen schlafen kannst du zu hause
ge und nimmt den boden feucht auf
meine neue wohnung gefällt mir
es gibt einen großen fernseher eine
teure stereoanlage und bequeme möbel
das ist eine tolle aussicht
wow die küche ist groß und hat viel
platz
das bad ist toll ich gehe gleich einmal
duschen
jetzt bin ich müde
das war eine lange reise jetzt schlafe
ich zwei oder drei stunden
ich muss mit dir sprechen
komm mit ins sitzungszimmer tina ich bin
nicht zufrieden mit seiner arbeit
du bist immer müde und deine motivation
ist auch nicht sehr gut
ich arbeite auch nicht gerne hier immer
sind alle so unfreundlich
ich möchte in einem richtigen restaurant
arbeiten und nicht in einem burger laden
und der lohn ist auch schlecht wissen
sie was ich kündige das ist besser so
dann muss ich dir nicht kündigen
ich habe nämlich bereits einen neuen
angestellten gefunden
lisa ich bin gerade sehr verärgert
hallo tina was hat dich denn so
verärgert
ich habe gerade meine stelle gekündigt
mit meiner chefin komme ich einfach
nicht klar
das klingt nach stress willst du bei mir
einen kaffee trinken kommen und darüber
sprechen
sehr gerne komme ich zu dir
ich bin in 20 minuten da
gut ich bereite schon einmal den kaffee
vor
[Musik]
der park ist super es tut gut spazieren
zu gehen
ich gehe jetzt zurück in die stadt
morgen ist nämlich ein wichtiger tag
ich beginne mit meiner neuen arbeit
das wird ein spannender neubeginn
[Musik]
[Applaus]